welcome to Hannity tonight warning signs
for the Biden economy they are flashing
brighter than ever let's pause for a
second all of this is going to impact
you your families your loved ones your
friends your neighbors it's that bad
sadly we are on the verge of not just a
recession not just a downturn but a
full-fledged economic meltdown all of it
caused by the policies of Joe Biden and
the new green deal climate cult agenda
socialist Democrats we're going to break
it down and you and your family need to
act accordingly to protect yourselves
now Biden is failing so much so fast is
so weak so frail so decrepit major
Democrats they appear closer than ever
now to Jumping Ship look at your screen
uh Biden earlier today in Israel as
Tucker just showed you literally
appearing to not even know where to sit
down where do I sit down what do I do
let me say hello let me shake the hand
of the air hello air I mean it's not the
first time we see this and once again
appearing totally disoriented you know
thank goodness yes the Israeli Prime
Minister was ever with him helping him
Dazed and Confused now these latest
struggles come as Biden's agenda is
imploding here at home because yes it
was yet another day with another bad
horrific batch of bad economic news for
the Biden economy this is on top of
yesterday's you know for Biden this was
his 41 plus year record high inflation
9.1 percent today we learned that
wholesale inflation which is the measure
of inflation before it gets to you at
the retail level consumers is surging
even more a whopping 11.3 percent that
is nearly the highest number ever yet
another painful reminder of the failures
of this far left disastrous destructive
Biden economy frankly there are signs of
even more pain in the days and months
ahead and frankly years ahead so so
let's make this perfectly clear so you
and your families understand now pretty
much everything you're buying is costing
you a fortune more because of the
Reckless radical policies that Joe Biden
the climate alarmist cult indoctrinated
brainwashed into cling to like Manna
From Heaven remember inflation was 1.4
percent to be precise When Donald Trump
left the White House Joe Biden lied back
in December he said oh inflation is only
transitory it's only temporary I think
the worst has passed us look at these
look at the graphs they speak for
themselves put together by the New York
Post look at this and it lays out just
how major and massive Biden's inflation
failures really are now you go to the
grocery store that's costing you more
you go to pump up your car with gas
that's costing you more than double what
you were paying under Trump you want to
take your family out to dinner good luck
that's costing you more you want to buy
a new car that's going to cost you
Fortune War probably above MSRP because
they don't have the parts available want
a used car that's up dramatically want
to renovate your house that's costing
you more but when the housing market
crashes and it will crash you might be
able to finally find that contract
you've been waiting for if you want to
buy a house yep interest rates are way
up it's going to cost you perhaps
thousands more every month and you have
interest rates spiking the FED is now
moving closer to a historic 100 basis
point increase later this month on top
of the 0.75 basis point increase we had
last month we haven't seen this since
Jimmy Carter but according to Biden the
Democrats we're all supposed to just
suck it up go along with their
anti-energy Green New Deal economy
killing agenda as the hard-working men
and women in this country and their
families suffer more and more and more
we're all supposed to believe their
Endless Lies and we're supposed to
pretend that this was all caused by
Putin and the panda
the pandemic was happening under
President Trump we didn't have these
problems we're paying we've got cheap
oil because it was domestic oil we were
energy independent and a net exporter of
energy Joe gave all of that up so Joe
blames big oil or blames rich people now
blames this week the Republicans blames
Donald Trump blames Fox News listen to
One White House so-called economic
advisor with next to no experience
completely stumble after actually being
asked a tough question Believe It or Not
by fake news CNN take a look the rate of
inflation in the U.S is higher than it
is in Canada France Italy Japan India
Mexico China
why
well here's a couple of things I mean
first off let's be clear the bulk of the
increases in prices last month were due
to energy and food and most of that was
indeed due to energy and so this is
really the result of you know the united
states and countries everywhere coming
out of historic pandemic where we have
seen these ongoing challenges with
Supply chains these fragile Supply
chains that businesses have created
around the world that have made it
difficult to get products to shelves in
the time of this recovery from a
pandemic you add on top of that this
unprovoked war that Putin has been
waging in the Ukraine and that is why
we've seen prices rise
she's right about the energy part except
she's not telling you the main part the
main part being of course that Joe Biden
well he eliminated energy Independence
somehow he thinks it's better to import
oil from countries that hate us like
Russia Iran Saudi Arabia OPEC Venezuela
now many in the mob and the media there
you know they're still in a never-ending
fight with truth and reality still on a
never-ending crusade to defend Biden at
all costs listen to the ladies at that
hard-hitting ABC News show The View
letting us know there's nothing Joe can
do yes there is drill and Frack but take
a look and inflation rates just hit a
40-year high and there are calls coming
from both sides of the aisle and the
media for the Biden Administration to
figure out ways to fix it so here's my
question what do you want him to do that
he's not doing I mean I don't I don't
know you know
this
I don't know very many folks who could
juggle this many balls in the air at
same time
especially not this guy who probably
doesn't know today's Thursday uh how
about this Whoopi he can return to the
economic and energy policies of Donald
Trump Donald Trump achieved energy
Independence for the first time in 75
years we're a net exporter of energy and
his clinging to new climate alarmist
religious cultism caused us all now to
pay double what we were paying
everything that's delivered to every
store you go to costs more because
diesel costs more Joe Biden artificially
reduced the world's supply of energy
supply and demand crisscross that
dictates dictates the price and guess
what demand remained constant the price
went dramatically higher Joe Biden
repeatedly attacking the oil and gas
industry they want to the leases back
they want to finish the Keystone XL
pipeline they want exploration in Anwar
all of which Joe is prohibiting Joe
rolled back at American Energy
Independence and we're all paying the
price so that's what he could do if Joe
Biden you know he said during the
campaign he would eliminate fossil fuels
look me in the eye trust me I'll
eliminate it I'll get rid of it it's Joe
Biden that signed into law of the
so-called covet relief bill that was not
actually for coveted perhaps the most
Reckless irresponsible piece of
legislation in modern U.S history that
fired up and already overheated economy
does the administration have no
understanding of inflation at all
whatsoever we learned yesterday from
Steve Moore they have next to zero
experience in the in the business sector
and beyond all the Biden lies and
misdirections and blame and you know all
the BS the signs of an economic disaster
or staring all of us right in the face
inflation 41-year High Energy prices
record highs and just this week the IMF
cut their 2022 growth forecast and
warned that avoiding a recession will be
quote increasingly challenging meaning
not going to happen that soft Landing
they talk about that's not going to
happen either now add to that the cooler
consumer spending weak Bank earnings
slumping stocks rate hike fears you have
a brutal Biden economic cocktail and
it's only just begun wait do you see
what happens new home construction is
going to stop sale of existing homes
will stop home values will plummet
nobody's going to want to sell their of
their home with a three percent 30-year
mortgage and move to another home and
guess what that's going to impact the
economy wait for the housing market
crash that's going to follow all of this
the man in the White House clearly is
not up for the job we should really have
an honest conversation if he's not up
for the job we really need to consider
the 25th Amendment Piers Morgan is right
and just in case you weren't quite
convinced let's remind you once again
the political coverage that look
[Music]
um
some of the political
players and some of the uh
let me ask you rhetorical question
[Applause]
so finally even the New York Times
recognizes wow Sean Hannity's been right
the whole time we were way ahead of the
curve we were telling you during the
campaign let me get a little ahead of
the curve again that man is not mentally
fit to be president and the people
around him covering all of this up they
are the worst type of enablers because
they're putting the country at greater
risk even the world at a greater risk
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else